I think there's something very worrying
happening as it were on the left you
know something it used to be that it was
the Conservatives both in America and
Europe who used to criticize people for
criticizing religion you know that used
to be a right-wing polemic now it's
become a left-wing dynamic you know that
that somehow and I think the argument
goes that Muslim groups in America and
Western Europe are often economically
disadvantaged and suffer from various
kinds of prejudice and racism and and
have difficult lives and therefore to
criticize the religion is to further
attack them and that should be done look
and I mean that's as as best as I can
put that argument no and I think that
was the argument in that Affleck issue
and I think it was the argument in the
division within Penn American Center
about honoring Charlie Hebdo and it
crops up over and over again and I mean
and and it happened to a certain extent
when when the trouble was surrounding me
but but actually less so then in those
days the argument was the criticisms
were still mostly from the right from
people like you know the Cardinal of New
York or the chief rabbi of Great Britain
or the Pope you know all of whom found
it post perfectly possible to sympathize
with Islamic religious leaders about me
you know so and that taught me something
interesting about the unity of the God
Squad you know now it seems that this
liberal spirit of appeasement of
political correctness is a new problem
it's because of course it's it's
obviously quite right to say that
communities that are discriminated
against and oppressed and economically
disadvantaged need to be need to have
those issues looked at you know and we
need to try to deal with those issues
that's not the same thing as saying you
can't criticize ideas they seem to hold
you know if you can't ring-fence ideas
it's one thing to say people must not be
discriminated yes but to say that ideas
become illegitimate or legitimate
because they're held by disadvantaged
people is it's there's just it's just a
flaw and it's very important to remember
that when free expression is diminished
or restricted it's usually minority
groups that suffer first its it it's the
it's their free expression that is that
is restricted before the majorities you
know so so it's always in the interests
of minority communities to defend free
expression because their own rights are
involved you know and and if by doing
that they have to put up with a certain
amount of criticism of their own ideas
than that just that just goes with the
territory and it's very worrying to see
well-meaning people people who were
coming from a good place
joining in with the with the world of
censorship and therefore ending up in a
very bad place and I think it's
perfectly legitimate to be highly
critical of religion in general and in
particular right now the use is being
made of the Islam Islamic religion
because of I mean just look what's
happening in the world you know we have
to I think to say that that's not to do
with Islam is just a logical
impossibility of course it is everybody
who if everybody engaged in acts of
Islamic terrorism says that they're
doing it in the name of Islam who are we
to say they're not you know I mean now
of course
what they mean by Islam might well not
be what most Muslims mean by Islam but
but it's still a form of Islam and it's
a form of Islam that's become
unbelievably powerful in the last 25 or
30 years a form of Islam that it that
oppresses and kills Muslims more than
anyone else that's to say most of the
Muslim deaths in the world right now are
not caused by American drones they're
caused by Islamic attacks on Muslims on
Muslims of another type you know Shia
attacks on Sunnis Sydney attacks on
shares most of the oppression of Muslims
in the world right now is carried out by
other Muslims you know whether whether
it's the Taliban in Afghanistan or you
know or the ayatollahs in Iran or
wherever it might be but but to say that
this is not Islam is to miss name the
problem the problem is that there's a
being a meaner mutation in Islam which
has become unusually virulent and
powerful and it needs to be dealt with
budget budget but in order to deal with
it we have to first call it by its true
name